[Applaudissements]
on
il y en avoir il agacé 0
[Musique]
avec toi et comment décider j'adore
jouer il
j'adore j'adore poule mais le point
décisif c'est le double est garant
perdez le doublon perdre est assez clair
que c'était important c'est un trésor
d'arganier est franchement quand on se
fait un truc on sent en deux points
gagnant deux points gagnants montrichard
des prières si tu gagnes
si tu gagnes franchement demain je sais
que vous faites un truc à l'entraînement
ouais vous mettez tout nous ils doivent
faire des services ltd fait devient
césaire qui me met cul nu et tous les
tous les chroniqueurs dois me viser
blessés si tu gagnes en revanche si je
gagne prochain tournoi est un t-shirt
avec by the king est le pari est pris
c'est parti on y va comment la joue
comme tu le sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à trois décennies par décider de partir
et chaussées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pathétique à paris
voir les lumières en effet
un joueur excellent carnet 4 7 6 7 4
[Applaudissements]